thank you
so thank you for the round of applause
it's great to see
all of you um this is my fourth thought
leaders
um event and it just still warms my
heart to see tom because i still
remember
about was it about 20 years ago when you
first started calling with all those
crazy ideas so where tom sort of
i don't know where he came from but one
day he started calling me until and
started saying we're going to build the
greatest entrepreneurship center in the
world
and i thought he was just this crazy
person from industry was looking for a
place to hide
but i just actually think tom with a
whole bunch of other people tina came
aboard quickly it's actually happened
and i just sort of stay out of the way
because i don't like working as hard as
as they do or with all those other
people tom's always around other people
i like being alone
so um as a transition the
as compared to people who do things more
socially
what my basic mode of operation is that
i spend years locked in my garage
trying to type my way out of solitary
confinement and every few years i emerge
with a book and so this
is the latest book so that's what
happened um
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
talk about this book scaling up
excellence which my colleague huggy rao
here he is
excuse me cute that that huggy rao
and i just had published about two weeks
ago actually less than that actually
last week
and um it's called scaling up excellence
and this has been a pretty interesting
adventure because in addition to my
usual
staying in my garage and trying to type
my way out of solitary confinement
one thing that huggy and i realized this
was a seven year project
was that scaling was a complicated
enough
topic compared to say which
really are not that complicated a topic
to tell you the truth
it was a complicated enough topic
that that we actually had to talk to
people who were knee
deep in the process of scaling so those
of you from the design school will
recognize customer focused design or
human-centered design
what we tried to do and it's your you
can judge
was to both do case studies go to the
academic literature
but to also keep presenting versions of
our id
ideas to people who had been or were
knee-deep in the process of trying to
spread excellence
and to get their feedback so it's a
different sort of book compared to
any book i've ever written in terms of
the process so
this is when we say scaling it's a word
or term that's used in many ways this is
the way
we define it for this book and really
going back six or seven years ago
we decided this is the puzzle we would
try to make some progress on
if anybody ever tells you they have
solved all your problems for scaling
they're lying to you you should send
them out the door immediately this is
just the best we can do right now
you've got an organization it's got a
center or pocket of excellence
essentially how can you spread it
further to places it perhaps deserves to
go
without screwing it up and that's sort
of what the book is about
uh some of you most of you are too young
or perhaps from other places
but some of you will have heard of pete
seeger the famous folk singer who just
died at the age of 94
a couple of weeks ago when we're in the
process of the book i saw him
interviewed
on tv and he was talking about
situations where
the only thing that's wrong with it is
there isn't enough of it
and that's sort of another way to think
about the problem that we were trying to
wrestle with
so to give you some examples
manufacturers will know about
pulse which was a company found in the
stanford d school in about
2010 and they were recently sold i think
last year to linkedin for 90 million
bucks
um we talked to ankit and akshay
occasionally in the course of them sort
of growing their company
and the process of growing from four
well four seven
eleven to twenty was actually quite
painful and difficult
um they they sort of got through it but
when you show people in big corporations
those numbers they say huh but if you're
in a startup those numbers really are
difficult to manage
little different sort of examples
mcdonald's is right now sort of
somewhere in between opening 1500 stores
in china
that's a different sort of scaling
example but they are trying to spread
their goodness
from if you will from the many many to a
few more i guess in this case
one of the heroes of the book and
somebody who i guess i've consulted to
uh was involved in the d school for
years still teaches in the d school
one of our scaling hero heroes claudia
kochka um
about 14 years ago the first time a.g
lafley was ceo of procter
gamble she started a little innovation
group
she had one product she was working on
and she just had a couple of folks and
over the course of seven or eight years
she sort of spread out so she sort of
essentially
we called connect and cascade created a
bunch of innovators and sort of stuck
them in p g businesses now they're in
about 30 different p
g businesses so that's again from the
few to the many and finally
a case with all the bad news you hear
about how bad our medical care
is in the united states it's good to
have some good news
between about 2004 and 2006 one of our
favorite examples
there was something called the hundred
thousand lives campaign
where a small non-profit hundred people
in boston the campaign team was about 12
or 13 people
what they did was they spread um
life-saving practices
very simple things like uh like getting
physicians and
nurses to wash their hands they have
incredibly filthy hands it's
amazing how dirty doctors hands are it
sounds obscene but it's true
and things like if you have a relative
on the respirator
on a respirator if the bed isn't tilted
up at least 45 degrees the odds of
pneumonia go way up
so they spread really simple practices
and it looks like
and mike author huggy rao is one of the
sharpest quantitative researchers around
it looks like this set of interventions
which were
spread across hospitals in the u.s saved
about a hundred and twenty three
thousand lives of sort of huggies best
guess
so these are all different but they're
all similar in that what the challenge
is to spread something good
even further so to us that's what
scaling is all right
so our core message is when we see
something good at least that seems good
to us spread
the people who scale badly and this is
classic in startups
they get so focused on running up the
numbers
that they don't realize that in the
process what they really need to do
is to slow down and spread behaviors and
beliefs
we call this a mindset that sort of are
in everybody's brain
that propel scaling and we would argue
that a hallmark of effective scaling
is essentially as huggy puts it people
know when to hit the brakes
so they can accelerate faster later and
he's got this new line
but the great thing about brakes is it
means you can drive even faster
and it's kind of the same with with
scaling
i was just with huggy at google
yesterday doing the talk
and google's a really great place you
can go back to even 2002 i remember
interviewing larry page
he talked about how pissed everybody was
at him the venture capitalist
his fellow employees and also stanford
students because he wasn't hiring them
fast enough
but it turns out that focusing on hiring
the right people was very important to
google's growth
another example facebook with
we've had intermittent contact with the
folks at facebook since the earliest
days of the d
school when a woman named katie
germander who is then head of products
used to come and
hire our students from the d school in
fact the other day i sent an email
because she saw that our book came out
and she gave me a list of four or five
people she sort of just hired right out
of our class i sort of forgot about that
but we've been following them for a long
time and the guy we talked to in
particular is a guy named chris cox
another famous stanford draft but he
actually finished his undergraduate
degree and dropped out of symbolic
systems
chris cox has now had a product um and
um
and in talking to chris and other folks
like trap mike tropher
who's the cto they um described to us
and we also talked to a lot of the
other engineers that it at facebook
when they hire a new engineer because
getting the mindset in people is so
important
when you're hired before they assign you
to a job
what they have you do is they have you
do 12 or 13
small projects and we've all heard
probably most of us about the move fast
and break things mindset
the idea here is you actually live it
and when we had uh mike tropher schrepp
and chris cox as guests in our class
i said to um chris cox what's a good
first week at facebook
and he said you've made a change in the
code
that you can show to your mother or
father like a new pull down menu
maybe higher resolution on a picture and
that's that's sort of
this notion that we see over and over
again that when firms scale effectively
they think about the mindset
not just the footprint as huggy would
put it um
then let me sort of warn you here that
the kind of mindset that you need to
scale an organization
is going to vary wildly from
organization to organization depending
on what the
what they're trying to do what the
strategic intent is what's most
financially viable for them
and so around um the time was probably
2009 2010 i was sort of in trance with
the
move fast and break things mindset of
facebook there's a vmware executive and
vmware vmware's just sort of like up the
street on uniprocera
and i said do you move fast and break
things
and he said no especially in our unit
that builds software for nuclear
submarines because it was not like the
right
software and so this is one thing you
got to kind of keep in mind
is that the best organizations have
mindsets
the right mindsets but they have the
right ones that are for them
um but the constant that we see in
effective mindsets
whether it's people making like a
software for nuclear submarines
or um or or a facebook is there's always
this relentless restlessness that's a
brad bird from pixar the academy
award-winning director of ratatouille
um and the incredibles and when huggy
and i interviewed
him in that in 2008 he described how
that was his attitude and how many times
he got
fired because when he got around people
like at disney in the very old days the
simpsons he got fired because they
didn't have the relentless restlessness
to make things better all the time so i
think that's a hallmark of
of the ones that are effective all right
so that's
sort of the if you will the warm-up or
the beginning
and what i'm gonna do just to give you
since i've been teaching so long i'm
going to go to about 20 after
maybe a little i'm shorter and then
we'll sort of get to questions
but this is sort of our view about what
it takes to scale well
the first one is that one thing that
really struck us is in organizations
where the workforce sort of propels
the spreading of goodness there's this
real feeling of accountability
and by accountability it's the feeling
that i own the place
and the place owns me that everybody
puts pressure on everybody else if you
will
to do the right thing and to switch to
the medical organizations we actually
both hugging i got fairly obsessed with
health care
it's really interesting to look at the
difference between most hospitals
where when they've got i'm not supposed
to go that far when they when they've
got
a you know somebody who is near death
usually with a head injury
and they want to harvest the organs and
has given permission and everything
most hospitals sort of get that right
about 50 percent of the time
about 15 of hot u.s hospitals get it
right about 75
of the time and in those hospitals they
have a set of norms
where everybody's involved in making
sure that everybody does the right
things the nurses
the doctors the clergy the receptionist
they pull in family members who have
been in the same situation before and
there's this notion where they all teach
and they all learn and to us that's a
hallmark of organizations that spread
excellence is this feeling of
accountability
in in in organizations where there's not
silence where people feel compelled
to tell other people when they're
screwing up or to teach them or to help
them
idea is a good example of that too the
second thing and something that huggy
and i have written a lot about
is sometimes we call scaling the problem
of more because when you're scaling like
you got something good you're spreading
it to more places to more people
you're trying to grow pulse you're
trying to open more mcdonald's or more
in and out burgers
but the other thing that we emphasize is
scaling is actually a problem of less
as well because there are a whole bunch
of things that will maybe used to work
and don't work anymore and you got rid
of them and there also might be things
you've always done that actually slow
you down you don't realize it
so to give you a few illustrations i did
not think i would live long enough to
see the president the united states fire
the ceo of general motors but i did live
that long
and when um when obama fired the ceo
general motors
he brought in a guy named ed whittaker
who was ceo of a t
and uh and this the video's on but it
doesn't matter
as a taxpayer i've given enough money to
general motors i can say this
um so um so there were a group of us in
our department
who worked with the general motors r d
organization
for about seven or eight years at any
time
we came up with an idea about how they
actually had to make things better
they had what we called the know we
can't mindset and the reason was almost
always because that's a good idea
but it's too difficult to do because and
one of the reasons was they always had
to write reports and i was pleased to
see that ed whitaker
you see sort of made this little change
going from 94 to 4 required reports
we actually are going to have some
general motors senior executives here
next week who huggy and i are going to
meet with
and i'm going to be really curious to
see what happens because my goal is to
give them as much grief as possible and
see if they're making any progress
anyway
an organization i have a long-standing
both love and hate for
um an organization i have only
long-standing love for
is ido an ideo i've known for a long
time
in the mid 90s one of my former doctoral
students andy hargenan and i did
a 15 month 16 month ethnography there we
really hung out a long time
and in those days they had about 60
people and the guy in the middle
with the mustache that's david kelly
that's that's what he used to look like
he's always been involved unlike me in
some of my earlier talks i'm actually
not bald in this seminar
um but in those days there'd be about 60
people in palo alto at the monday
morning meeting
and david was absolutely masterful he'd
start out with a joke or a story
the thing that he usually started out in
those days he wasn't married he usually
talked about the bad date he had over
the weekend so that sort of warmed
everybody up
and then he'd go around the room and
he'd get
just about everybody to talk or he'd say
something about you so we were the
ethnographers
and he would say they're watching you
they're they're
you know writing down everything you say
we've got spies in which actually we
were writing down everything they said
to the extent we could
and one of the things that we wrote down
was this notes that almost everybody
would talk and participate because we
you know record comments and
count and stuff then ideo grew to about
150 people
and i remember going to this monday
morning meeting sort of towards the end
it was absolute hell it just did not
work they reached a scale where
what got them there won't get them the
next level
then there's stuff that everybody else
does that's incredibly stupid
and you do it too just because everybody
else does it and
our number one example and one we've
gotten quite obsessed with
our yearly performance evaluations has
anybody here ever given a yearly
performance evaluation
anybody ever had one yeah we have them
at stanford i have no idea
how it works i have no idea the
relationship between what i do and how
much i get paid
what happens is i go to the secretary
i'm gonna get in trouble for this
and you get the envelope and the
envelope has your pay in it that's our
whole performance evaluation process i
thought this incredibly long form
i'm always late i forget what happens
and i never can remember what i was paid
the year before so i have no idea how i
did
um so anyways just you literally get a
number so we have a terrible performance
evaluation system
which i like i think is good because my
interpretation is i can do whatever i
want so i don't understand the
performance evaluation system
so for me it's good but if you don't
have tenure it's probably not good
anyway so so to look at an organization
do not show this to my department chair
please um so
so if you if you look at an organization
that we've been following is in the book
adobe actually got rid of yearly
performance evaluation
um this this incredibly um brave woman
donna morris actually had the guts to do
it
and she had a really logical reason
which was every year at adobe when they
did their yearly
sort of a stack ranking performance
evaluation sort of general electric
style
uh first of all good employee
satisfaction numbers they'd go down
they had good evidence that the best
people would leave and it took 80 000
person hours to
do and 80 000 person hours you could
have a pretty big startup going for
example
and so they got rid of them and i won't
go into the details just in the name of
time
but they came up with a sort of check-in
system where what you do
is your boss is responsible for actually
constantly giving you feedback
throughout the year
and and my favorite in your body and
then you evaluate your boss and how good
the feedback is so it's sort of turned
upside down
and my favorite part is what donna said
is we took all the forms and all the
technology away from these engineers
that
we have at adobe and we force and we're
trying to force them to learn how to
actually talk to their people
and i thought that was a pretty good
solution okay and we'll see what happens
the early numbers look like it's working
but at least they had the guts to try it
okay
so so those are the two big lessons and
we're pretty cool on time
so now so this is sort of an interesting
writing process so
the problem with having too much time to
write a book as huggy and i do since
it's like the nearer i get to death
the more time i think i have to do stuff
it's completely irrational but that's
one reason i think we took seven years
for this um
for this uh project and there was one
point and somewhere in my office it may
still be there
huggy and i actually had you know sort
of d-school style
um post-it notes of every decision we
could think of
that were major decisions you would make
in the process of scaling an
organization about 50 of them
and since we were too compulsive we
tried to write everyone up
and in the end we would always come back
to the same dimension
and this and this comes from since some
of us or many of us are from stanford
how many of you have had michael dearing
in the class has anybody had michael
dearing in the class a few people
teaches lunch bad
okay so we're sitting around it's about
2006 early days of the d
school and michael says uh
so when the d school is we start
expanding
um are we going to be catholics or
buddhists i would note that michael has
a very catholic
background in fact he likes to point out
he was ultra boy of the month many times
so he's a very strong catholic
so he said are we going to be sort of
like what happens
um you know the mass in the vatican is
it can be replicated everywhere so is it
going to be like
what happens at the d school in palo
alto it's just replicated in every class
and everywhere throughout the world
or are we going to be buddhists where we
have sort of like a vague mindset
and we do sort of local standardization
or customization whatever sort of
strikes you that's within the sort of
vague mindset
well this turned out to be quite a
brilliant comment because
once you start going to the scaling
literature the question of
whether we're trying to do the same
thing everywhere else in the exact same
way or whether we allow local
customization is a
constant and never-ending decision that
never goes away at the strategic
sort of kathy eisenhart level or even at
the most sort of focused individual
level
and just to give you some examples you
look at
and out burger incredibly catholic
organization they're all nearly perfect
replicants of one
of one another intel much of their
especially they're
changing this a little bit now their
years of success was based on the copy
exactly method in manufacturing firms
but there's this risk where if you start
thinking that something is so great
it'll work
everywhere you suffer from what uh
actually education researchers call the
replication trap
and a good example of this is so home
depot it's about 2008
they decide that they're gonna move to
china and what they do is they take
you know the home people store sort of
like we have in east palo alto
they open 12 of them in china and they
try to sell the chinese people on the
do-it-yourself approach
it's a do it for me sort of culture and
it's a
chow wong one of my former students now
harvard mba
said to me he's from china he said if
you have enough money to shop at the
home depot in china
you have enough money to pay somebody to
um do to do it for you and that's also
how they think about it so
this didn't work the last store closed
in 2012.
in contrast ikea is just kicking ass in
china
and one of the reasons they're doing so
well is they've done a bunch of local
customization
probably 80 percent of the stuff they
sell is the same stuff they sell in east
palo alto
but they've done stuff like um they've
they have really great delivery services
because many chinese people don't have
cars and the ones that do don't have as
big a cars
as americans do and also they're not
into that assembly thing
so it's assumed when you buy that stuff
that somebody's going to come to your
house and assemble it
it's some it's so there was some sort of
local adaptation
so they kind of did a tilt toward
buddhism we would say
in the situation where buddhism is
probably especially valuable
are situations where you kind of know
the mindset you need but you don't know
the best solution
and you know there's going to be a lot
of need for localization a good example
and yes another one of my medical
examples is um
in in the medical literature it's very
well known that when your nurse
and it's usually a nurse who gives you
drugs when your nurse gets interrupted
or distracted
they screw up the medicine they're going
to give us so the whole goal
in hospitals and this is by the way if
you have a loved one who's giving drugs
to
um and there's a nurse giving that
person drugs do not talk to them or
interrupt them it's
good advice anyways so so there was a
program put on by
university of california san francisco
where what they did was they took a
whole bunch of local
groups of nurses and they said you
figure out how to stop the interruptions
in your nursing unit
so here's one this is actually
university of california san francisco
you can't see in the picture but she's
actually in an enclosed room with drapes
so nobody can see her and she's sorting
the medicine
but here's another one she's using see
she's got this do not interrupt
thing on this is actually to the back of
her is it's a neonatal intensive care
unit
so i mean she wants to be able to see
the babies and you see sort of the
different solutions
and here it's always important to
remember so that's a buddhist approach
that worked
um in general you know the question of
where to be
on the buddhism catholicism um sort of
dimension here
is is a constantly changing and
strategic and tactical choice i
emphasize that
but one of the times when it's most
dangerous to have too much buddhism
is when people have this delusion that
they're so
unique they're so special that the rules
don't apply to them
and many of you stanford students know
this when you deal with tenured faculty
like me we think we're so special
the rules shouldn't apply to us doctors
are just as bad
and a great example of when this can be
dumbed was uh that o'toole gawande this
is an article in the new yorker
looked at a group um at the hospital he
was at in boston
that did re knee replacements and there
was this guy john wright
who was at war with his colleagues for
seven or eight years to get them to do
more
standardization and they fought him at
every turn and most of them still don't
like him
but look at the numbers cut cost by 50
patients leave about a day earlier
so sometimes ramming a little bit of
standardization down people's throat is
maybe the best solution for all
but the buddhism catholicism thing it's
probably the most important decision
points that we
talked about in the book okay i'm going
to go about 25 more minutes
here are some of the scaling principles
some of the big ones
let me start with the first one so
this comes from huggy rao's research on
social movements
so it turns out that even though we're
at a place like stanford
where we're all smart people can make
logical arguments
it turns out to change human behavior
especially collective human behavior
that just making a rational argument
won't work
and and the basic recipe is as huggy
would put it
first you get the emotions cranked up
you get the hot cause cranked up
and then you link it to a tangible
set of solutions so to give you a good
example i already mentioned the
the ihi the hundred thousand lives
campaign
when they kicked off that movement they
brought together at a large conference
about four thousand different folks from
hospitals from the insurance industry
from the
american medical association and they
had in two of the speeches they have
one was from swirl king whose daughter
josie
died from a series of preventable
medical errors
at johns hopkins hospital and um sorel
said please don't let this what happened
to my daughter happen at your hospital
so
hot cause cool solution and my favorite
part
so in huggie did this case one of the
other speakers was sister mary
jean ryan who ran a large uh
a large catholic hospital system in
florida and she basically said it's a
moral
imperative or as i would translate it if
you don't
join the hundred thousand lives campaign
you're gonna go to hell so that's a real
hot cause
um but then there was the cool solutions
you are gonna adopt you know some of
these six practices
um just real quickly i don't want to
spend a lot of time in this but huggy
and i
about well we started this is about two
or three years ago
we taught a class to try to get stanford
undergraduates to wear helmets let's do
a quick
how many separate undergraduates we got
here raise your hand keep your hand off
if you wear a helmet
it didn't work very well but anyways so
uh
we're still trying though if you get in
a serious accident and you're you have
more risk of injury if you wear a helmet
so anyways so what what happened was um
we sent out this group our groups of
students and we had them sort of
basically deal with groups of undergrads
and try to get them to wear helmets
in one of the groups they did what they
called the watermelon offensive
this was with the men's soccer team and
they tried to convince him to wear
helmets they made a rational argument
this did not work at all
so what they did was they started
smashing broken watermelons everywhere
and they put little things on their
handlebars i had one in my office
that were basically a picture of
somebody next to a smashed watermelon
with a crash bike sort of lying there
without a helmet on
and they kind of got them laughing and
going and it's also you know sort of a
light but gruesome metaphor
and then they got them to start wearing
the helmets so
so this was at least for about seven
weeks this was effective and as we can
tell
from the survey here we're having no
lasting impact at all and we can talk
about when scaling
sticks the other thing is
when it comes to creating a hot cause
people are good at creating a hot cause
are the masters of naming the problem or
better or worse yet
naming the enemy and you know jobs this
is like a long quote from steve jobs i
don't think i'm going to
read but the basic sort of upshot of
this is he comes back to apple after
being gone
and uh somebody one of the first things
he hears at all hands meeting is that
michael dell once
says you should shut down the company
and give it back the money back to the
shareholders
job says michael dell typical
jobsian sort of thing
this is from john lilly who's spoken in
this and then everybody gets kind of
worked up
because they're getting emotion
especially that sort of apple pride you
got sort of you know
either do a great job or get out but
there's also a cool solution
he gives them a three-year vest for
their stock rather than a one-year vest
and john describes how effective this
was and throughout jobs career he was a
very complicated character
and i'm not sure i would want to have
worked with him but
he one of his hallmarks was just getting
pissed at people i mean
sort of in his dying days he called up
larry page and screamed at him and
threatened him
because google was allegedly stealing
stuff that by the way apple had probably
stolen from somebody else
um but but that was sort of his mode of
operation
okay so when you do this though the key
hallmarks are
you arouse collective pride and
aggression
when you look at work by sociologists
and psychologists
they say a lot of what happens in this
process of sort of social movement
is people get the emotions cranked up
and they stop thinking about their
self-interest
and they start thinking more about the
collective interests
okay so that's the first one i'm going
to
grab a click quick thing of water here
the second one is live a mindset don't
just talk about it
so there's a large body of psychological
research
which essentially says that if you want
to change
people's beliefs um if you want to sort
of cement a mindset
what they say or what you say to them
well that's just fine
but what really changes the deep seated
beliefs we have is
is what our behavior is so you go to
facebook
which i've already talked about this is
a quote from chris cox
we don't talk about our mindset much
they kind of get an introductory lesson
or lecture from chris who still does it
from most people at facebook
uh maybe they give him a computer and
get them going but the idea is to live
the mindset
not to talk about it and it turns out
and there's good research to support
this
that even if people don't like the
direction you want them to go and don't
believe you
your job is to keep them marching in the
direction you want them to go
and there's a lot of evidence that their
beliefs will change as a result as long
as you keep them going
and by the way every major religion in
every in every major military uses this
technique to brainwash people
um but to give you uh so i actually
lost bonnie simmi but i'm going to tell
this story anyway so i took out one
slide too many
so there's this amazing stanford
graduate bonnie simmi
zwani is a three-time olympian in the
luge and for you undergraduates you will
love this
i sort of love this too there was one
point bunnies in her 50s now
she got a letter from the provost
putting her on academic probation
um in the same day she got a letter also
from the provost congratulating her for
making the us olympic team so she had an
interesting
sort of career well bonnie in addition
to doing all these olympic efforts she
became a pilot
and eventually became a pilot of jetblue
and and bonnie has since done all sorts
of stuff in the d-school along the way
she got
mba and a degree from management science
and engineer just just in the last five
or six years because she loves school so
much
and one of the reasons she got a degree
from msne is she wanted to learn about
operations
because some of us will remember in 2007
there was a terrible incident
where there were thousands of people
stuck on on planes at kennedy
and and bonnie believed that that was a
completely preventable problem
caused by the fact that um that jetblue
had outgrown its culture
its process and its i.t system has it
gotten too big it needed to go to a more
systemic approach
and after several top-down attempts to
stop it
to fix it they were so desperate they
let bonnie sort of try her trick which
was
initially to bring 40 and then in groups
of as much as 80 people together
and what they would do is out of the
d-school since she was very influenced
by the d-school
is so imagine a storm hits kennedy i
flew into kennedy last week and
all the planes there's like 4 000
flights canceled a storm hits kennedy
what's the process
of closing it and then reopening it and
doing as effectively as possible and
they'd map it with post-it notes
and wherever there was a pink post-it
note that meant there was a problem they
had to fix
very interdisciplinary teams
and so she did this she describes it and
she talked about this in my class
msne280 at one point
and she's all these folks doing this for
her and it's like the first day she's
got almost no budget
and she says to them there's about 40 of
them how many of you think this is going
to be effective
not a single one of them raised their
hands but they liked bonnie so they kept
sort of moving forward
and if you fast forward a few years this
process actually seems to have
largely fixed their operations during
difficult weather
and in the the you know the message here
is no matter what people are saying keep
them moving forward
okay we're pretty cool on time the next
one so
when you think about the problem of more
a lot of what you're doing is you're
doing things that add cognitive load to
people you're adding more procedures
you're adding more process you're adding
more people we'll talk about that more
and so so there's a lot of rhetoric and
it's probably correct
that if if you're doing that you should
follow a g lapse of these model and keep
things sesame street simple
and there's a great set of studies by a
guy named bobby shiv who now actually
teaches the stanford business school
he did it earlier in his career i think
it was a duke and he did a pretty simple
experiment where basically he had two
groups of people
and one group um you know typical
undergraduates who randomly assign them
to conditions
memorized a 16 did or a six i'm getting
this wrong a two-digit number i'm sorry
and and so just like 16 that's why i
said that like 16
and the other ones did a seven digit
number like three two four two two five
seven
and then what they did was they walked
to like the end of a hall so about where
the guy in the back is standing
and they reported the number but in
between was cake and fruit
so the question is what's the effect of
the cognitive load because trying to
remember that seven digit number is much
more difficult
than than remembering the two digit
number and the ones who did the
um seven digit number eight fifty
percent more cake
so so what happens is when you give
people cognitive load
that they sort of lose the will and
concentration on what's important so you
got to be careful with cognitive load
and one of my favorite examples another
stanford graduate
this is an attempt into it and no you
can't read this you're not
supposed to be able to read this to
bring essentially design
thinking to intuit this is they called
the d4d or design for delight movement
and again at one of these early sort of
kick-off things what they did was this
was presented
by karen hanson who has a phd in
psychology from stanford
and scott cook who's the largest
shareholder and co-founder of of intuit
and even the title was convoluted
evoking positive emotion
by going beyond customer expectations
and ease in benefit delivery throughout
the customer journey
so when we talked to cara and nicara and
let us talk about this in the book
she'll let me say this here she says it
to our classes she comes in and gives
lectures
she said people had two reactions to
this one they couldn't understand what
the hell we were talking about
and number two they had this reaction
that this too
shall pass and so we sort of had a
problem
and and pretty quickly they went to this
this is what they still use this is
their model
this is the only picture in the book
it's the light really simple and this is
a case i think of sort of learning that
making things as simple as possible but
no simpler is the way that you do
scaling
and here i hasten to add and there's
certain management theorists and i have
sort of a running polite squabble with
gary hamel over this who's a well-known
management guru he's always talking
about tearing down the bureaucracy and
tearing down the hierarchy
the fact is that as your organization or
project grows and gets more complex
you do need more roles you do need a
little bit more hierarchy you do need a
little process that's unavoidable
and and one guy who learned this is mr
larry page
um and it turned out when this is about
2003 or so
when google got up to about 400 people
he started longing for the good old days
when they didn't have those annoying
managers around
so we got rid of all the annoying
managers because he's larry page so he
could get rid of them
and he had a situation where there was
one
executive who had more than 100
engineers reporting to him this did not
last very long she's laughing well he
learned the hard way and now by the way
i just said google yesterday
doing some of the guy named parsad seti
who runs sort of
people analytics and now they're totally
into essentially
line supervisors are totally obsessed
with them and think it's one of their
keys to their success so they have
learned
so the lesson here is that as systems
and projects get bigger you've got to
add more complexity
but you've got to find some way to deal
with it that sort of um
acknowledges and incorporates human
limits so ben horowitz
of um of and drayson horowitz has got a
great line
that what you do is you put in just
enough structure process so you're
giving ground grudgingly
so in his perspective as you wait for
things to crack a little bit but not
break
and another expression this is one of
the heroes in the book really
interesting guy chris frye
who before he was at twitter he's now
head of engineering but before he was at
twitter he um and another guy named
steve green
they grew the development organization
from 40 to 600 folks
and he's got this great line that the
purpose of hierarchy is to destroy
bad bureaucracy and i think that's
that's about right
real quickly we don't have enough time
to go through sort of every aspect of
what it takes
to to have sort of a good um if you will
non-friction-filled bureaucracy
but if i was going to pick one lesson
the thing that
i think more organizations screw up than
anything else i would pick
group size there's a lot of evidence
that as a team gets bigger than five six
seven
eight gets near ten as richard hackson
quote said
things get really bad and essentially
what happens is you get around 10 or 11
12 13 you end up spending more and more
time on coordination chores
and less and less time actually doing
the work and the other thing that
happens
is that you start having all these
interpersonal problems because you think
about it
try to keep track of the personalities
and moods of 10 or 11 people
it's like going to dinner and trying to
have a conversation with 10 or 11 people
is like almost impossible
that's why the average restaurant
reservation the us is actually four
people so a little evidence to support
that
and a good example of a team that had
some struggle with this
was larry ellison's oracle usa team
eventually the 500 million dollars
or so that larry spent got them out of
this but
a year ago a little longer ago than that
there's a guy named perry claibonne
anybody had classes from perry claybound
at the d school
no hands one of my hero anyhow perry's
one of a great teacher i just saw han
um so perry somehow or another and i
don't understand how this happened
got to know jimmy spithill who was the
guy who actually won the last two
america's cup as skippers
and we kind of got a call that they had
some group dynamics issues and so
we went there and it's a long story but
we actually brought in one of our
friends from nascar and had him do a
tire changing exercise
but in the process they had this broken
sailboat laying around that's why they
had time to deal with us academics
and you may remember the story this was
october
last year so what happened was this is a
72 foot sailboat
and i am going to break the rules here
that's 72 feet this is about 110 feet
it's a 12 million boat this is about a
three million dollar mass basically
so this is in san francisco bay there's
an ebb tide the tides going out
now they're on the other side of the
golden gate bridge and here's their boat
okay
and what happened in part there's lots
of other explanations these boats are
really freaking hard to sail
but part of the problem was they had all
been racing in five person sailboats
and they moved to 11 and they had all
these coordination problems that they
had to deal with
and by the way they got better they came
back they won the americas cup
um but but that switch was really
interesting and by the way one of the
things that all the teams eventually
figured out with the 11
person teams is everybody on these boats
they're miked and they have headphones
for starts
it's so loud 72 feet they're going 50
miles an hour and like a 25 knot wind
you just can't hear anything
so what they figured out was they took
the microphones
away from five or six of them so they
could only hear and not talk
to keep down the complexity so that was
one of the solutions to sort of make
them like a small team
okay the next one and i'll move through
this one quickly this one's easy
when you see effectiveness spread
sometimes there's this tendency
and sometimes i get paid to do this like
i come in and give a scaling speech
or i come in and give an innovation
speech or any of the other books that
i've talked about in this
in this event and and some exactly will
be under the delusion that this will
actually change things to spread this
sort of thin code of effectiveness
sometimes organizations do this with a
full a little bit of training
but when you look where effectiveness
actually spreads what happens is
you get a deep pocket of excellence and
that's spread from one place to the
other
that's how the hundred thousand lies
campaign worked that's how a fast food
chain we worked with did it a little bit
an example of something that was real
simple and not too complicated to spread
um one of the cases we found out about
was in iraq there was a
interesting thing came out one group
noticed that when um that
the enemy threw rk uh rkg
three hand grenades sort of old soviet
union hand grenades
and they threw them against something
that was soft they wouldn't blow up
so one what they do is they put a
trampoline on the side of the truck okay
and something called the army center for
lessons learned spread it really quickly
and it's spread throughout
iraq so that's connect and cascade a
more complicated one
this is fifi she's at the pearl river
plant one of the cases that we wrote
uh and and what they did was they kind
of changed the mindset and approach
when they were doing changeovers in a
pharmaceutical plant to viewing it as a
time to rest as approach as opposed to
being a pit stop
and they had these mini transformation
these little areas of effectiveness and
they spread it throughout the
organization after that
um and then finally and this is our last
point and we're actually doing pretty
good on time
that book from good to great one of our
arguments is that good to great is great
but when you look at the spread of
effectiveness what we really see
is from bad to great is what really
happens and here's our argument why
so there's a lot of evidence from all
different parts of life
that bad is stronger than good stealing
corruption
uh fights uh laziness incompetence it's
stronger than good
it infects teams it's more contagious
there's a great article that students in
my class read called
bad is stronger than good that
reinforces this uh to tell you maybe the
most important thing you will hear today
for those of you who want to maintain
long-term personal relationships
uh there's good evidence that if you are
in a long-term relationship
and every time you have an argument or
fight with your um partner
or just an unpleasant interaction if you
don't make it up with at least five good
ones you are in trouble things are not
going to last
and the same thing happens when you go
into the workplace bad interactions pack
five times the wallop of good
interactions
if we have one deadbeat or jerk in your
team
it lowers performance by 30 or 40
percent so there's a lot of evidence
that
in order for good to spread what your
job is is to get rid of the bad first
so to give you one example one of the
class guests in our scaling class was a
guy named barry feld
and berryfell took over cost plus stores
this is about seven or eight years ago
the stock price was one they're on the
verge of going into bankruptcy
and so he had like 156 stores and he
walked around to most of them
visited most of them he closed some of
them
but he also did something at every store
that he went to which was
the first thing he looked for was do
they greet me or the customers and if
they didn't
he saw that as bad behavior because
it meant when people aren't greeted they
steal more and they buy less so what he
taught them to do and he do it on the
spot is
greet them and give them a basket so buy
more stuff so that was one little thing
and then the other thing is he looked to
see was if the bathrooms were clean
because he had learned from a career in
retail that when the bathrooms are dirty
it's connected to a whole bunch of other
problems
and eventually they were sold to bed
bath and beyond it was a good exit story
and getting rid of the bad is not
necessarily always getting rid of sort
of obnoxiously bad difficult things
sometimes it's little things that screw
up your group so this is from chris frye
who we're actually doing something at
the commonwealth club next week which
should be fun
he's now the head of engineering at
twitter so he takes over
engineering at twitter and he goes to
his first meeting with with his senior
team
and he looks and they're doing what
probably many of you are doing right now
they're all looking at their cell phones
and and he
says and he said we're having votes and
they're still looking at their cell
phones they're not even listening
so he took their cell phones away from
them and put them in a basket
and think about who works for twitter
the way he described it as they all
started vibrating because it was like
taking away their heroin
or something and um but he said we
actually have shorter more effective
meetings now
and and to me that you know we all know
about the distraction of cell phones and
like
but to me that's that's a pretty good
example of of getting rid of something
bad so the good can
spread okay we can move there's a
scaling principles a couple of wrap up
comments and we can have some
discussion hopefully uh the first thing
and this is really something that we
learned when we hear these words and
we're talking to people who are trying
to spread excellence
we don't have time to do it the way we
really should or we're going to take the
path of least resistance
we start getting nervous because there's
a lot of evidence that what ends up
happening is i'm going to get in trouble
from this but you'll end up like groupon
where you want to do things so quickly
that you screw up everything else you've
got to go back and redo it
it's it's it's this notion and in fact
if you look at research
on how educational intervention spread
there's a lot of evidence that the most
effective groups take the path of most
resistance
so i wish i could tell you was easy but
it is not easy and
there's no such thing as quick and easy
scaling we can identify
and related to this we're going to end
with you know my buddy and
you know the local and deserved hero
david kelly
um so i've been involved with two
different scaling efforts with david
one is an observer and the other is a
participant i learned it's much easier
to be an observer than a participant
by the way in the mid 90s through about
well even through now i've been an ideo
fellow so i sort of watched ideo scale
and there's lots of times when people
would be all upset and they go into
david's office and you just sort of tell
them to calm down that basically like it
says scaling's a manageable method
always seems screwed up you sort of
need that to move forward and i always
said david so wise he must be calming
them down
and then we started the d school and i
was actually helping to scale
and i was one of those people in david's
office hysterical or you know just sort
of like standing there because
everything was all screwed up what's
going to happen next we have no
procedures
people are fighting i mean with all due
respect to the d-school if you want good
group dynamics
in the senior team this is not a place
to go and it still isn't true
but david one thing that he does is he
sort of casts a spell over you as the
quote sort of says
that you clean up the best you can but
you got to keep moving
forward and this is kind of weird but
all and i'll end here
it always reminds me of research on
mood and even research on things like a
visit to disneyland which is sort of
interesting
and it turns out i think this is an
important thing for both leaders and for
our own mental health
that if you look at the average mood of
the average person
right now always sucks the most lots of
evidence
so how are you feeling right now versus
tell us about the past you know because
most of us have pretty good mental
health and we misremember how good
things were in the past
and we're pretty optimistic about the
future so
so a lot of what a leader's job is
is to change attention to move away from
how much the presence sucks
to thinking about of the great past and
especially how great things are gonna be
in the future
and i would argue to go back to david
and then we should open this up for
comments since i've
seen him scale one organization ideo and
been part of the other
one of david's tricks is that he he
moves your attention
to the to the next big thing in fact
some people work with david for years
describe it as next big thing management
so even though things that the d-school
are not perfect now and i would could
point away since which is screwed up
well we're going to the next big thing
so we're thinking about the future so
who cares about how screwed up things
are just going to keep scaling if you
will
so i think that's enough so maybe times
for some comments and questions and uh
don't believe everything i tell you is
always my
key motto so please argue with me so i
don't know how comments are
oh we have a plus okay so thank you
thank you
all right
comments questions disagreements i love
when people disagree with me
i can do cold calls i have students from
my classes here yeah uh do you see a
possibility for a consistent
organizational theory to emerge
or you think it will be forever limited
to contradictory
case studies wow so that's so
so you just said everything sucks in
organizational theory and will never be
any consistent there i actually
and i have been organizational theorists
for 30 years oh so the question is
is are we left with contradictory ad hoc
case studies or will there be a
consistent organizational theory
i'm really sorry but i actually think
that there's pretty consistent
organizational theory
um and i you know i've been an academic
for 30 years i just
some of the basic stuff that i'm talking
about is actually pretty predictable
which is
as organizations grow they need more
differentiated roles they need a little
bit of hierarchy but not too much so
there's not too much friction
they they need to have you know
groups that aren't too big and if you
sort of like go through the evidence
yes there are many areas where it's
difficult to figure out what to do
exactly in this situation
but but i i don't think it's as hopeless
as it all all seems
that said um can we come up with an
organizational theory
that's going to assure that you succeed
100 of the time
my view and this is this is very well
supported since we're in the uh the
thought leaders
series in entrepreneurship if you think
we're going to come up with a system
that increases the odds your starter is
going to succeed i see no hope at all in
the future
it's a darwinian system it's very
difficult to figure out what's going to
happen
but this has been going on as long as
possible but but i actually think that
that that
if you got together organizational
theorists although we at each
other at the market margin
there's probably 20 or 30 principles
that actually hold across
organizations but maybe none of them
will help you save your particular
organization
so we are stuck with the ad hoc case
studies
that was a good question i liked it
because obnoxious so it's good more
obnoxious question no i liked it
yes
growth and the amount of discretion
between what between
between the size of a company as it
grows and the ability to give the
employees
uh discretion discretion so the question
is that
to me is does that mean that that do our
smaller organizations do they
do they allow more autonomy and
discretion for employees i
i actually what i think is in a really
small group
that's probably true once you get to 30
people or 25 people
it's probably all the same because in a
really small group you can be
participative
but if you if you sort of look and then
you get to a certain size you need some
structure
and then what you can do though and
google's actually pretty good about this
and if you look at the changes that are
happening at zappos
you can create a system where the groups
are sort of self-managing
but you always need a little hierarchy
so so i think it sort of
goes like that and then it flattens out
and i think that's what
what the evidence the evidence says yeah
so um when you put on your
management consulting patent you look at
the
sequester the sequester you want me to
answer a question about the sequester
how do i know about the sequester i want
you to put your management consultant at
on washington
and how would you apply so i have been
asked just for the viewing audience i've
been asked to fix the congress okay so
so just just to let you know so
anything i say from here on is
okay but
that said when you look at situations
where the worst situation is when you
have a bunch of medium power
constituencies
and none of them can dominate is either
no dominating force
or there's no cooperation medium power
constituencies who dislike each other
always suck and i got to be careful
since you were at apple during those
days that was one of the problems that
apple has i'm going to switch to apple
because i don't know very much about the
government
well it was one of the problems that
apple had and when jobs took over
this incredible list i have somewhere of
every product they had like a bazillion
dif
there was like 16 different performers
whatever the hell performer was
and either you've got to have people who
are cooperative enough that they
are smart enough to do the right thing
or this is a good word for authority
that you have
when there's dysfunctional conflict you
have somebody come with an iron hand and
shoot everybody
or put them in line and this is exactly
what mr jobs did at aptly fired many of
my friends
so so the answer is either peace love
and understanding
or a 44 magnum at the top and and that
and that there sir is that's
organizational theory
that either you have true love peace
understanding and collaboration and
everybody is on the
same page and has the right mindset or
somebody comes in
and and has the power and we are
uncomfortable talking about power in u.s
society
and tom byers knows me as well as
anybody in this room
i hate receiving or giving authority i
just hate it
but the fact is as as an outsider
sometimes it actually works
um so i yes so you're looking at
characteristics of organizations
and their leaders in terms of being
buddhist versus catholic
yes um what do you think about the sort
of leaders themselves being
born or made do you think there are
other philosophies that may not lead to
a good organizational leader
boy that's an open-ended question so how
do i summarize that for the viewing
audience
are leaders born or made the answer is
yes
and so here's why so
and so this is so this is that's the
answer to so
so in the old days when i was a real
academic i actually
got involved in a bunch of these person
situation debates and essentially what
you have
is the behavior you see is is such an
interaction between person and situation
that untangling them is actually pretty
difficult
so yes there's some genetic loading but
but the fact is
and there are probably some people are
not genetically um prepared to be
um leaders including some i have a son
with asperger's syndrome i'm not sure he
should be
like leading a large company maybe he
could be a member of it but
um but but most people probably have
enough of the genetic loading to
actually
be in a leadership position and and what
depends is giving them the opportunity
to actually
do it and there are some people who
don't have a loading and i would go back
to the good old days of hewlett-packard
which used to be a great organization
god knows what it is now meg whitman has
a job that's even harder than being
governor of california she found it
um but but in the in the good old days
what they would do and have lots of
friends
deborah dunn who's teaching a class here
at the d school what they do
is if you were sort of a competent solo
player they'd give you one person to
lead
and see if you screwed it up and then
they give you a team
then they give you a little bit more and
when you do that it turns out that
leadership is a learned skill that most
but not all people can learn
and there are might there might be some
magical amazing leaders
but danny kahneman the nobel prize
winner in economics and i don't know
what happened to this data set
but at one point i heard a rumor he had
a data set
that if you randomly switch the ceos of
all the fortune 500 firms there would be
no change in the performance across the
fortune 500.
i know this is true and i think i
believe in leadership more than that
but uh but you know leadership's a
complicated thing
and that's a question that people i
think don't really know the answer to
but i do think that leadership is a
learned skill
i would emphasize that one more question
professor buyer says final question
yes sir give me a three-part question a
three-pointer
so the thing is that i feel like a lot
of us are going to be
working in the real world yeah most
likely we're going to be on the bottom
of the totem pole we're going to be like
a low individual say you're like in a
toxic environment
you're in an organization that's like
completely resistant to change
what do you do uh how do you incite
change and
yeah like well so so this is the
question uh someone you're
you're in an organization that sucks
what do you do and you're working there
is a low-level employee
yeah so so so to me real quickly
either you try to create goodness where
you're at
and this is the scaling thing and it
really is quite interesting that
there are some cases where people create
a little local goodness
and then it spreads in its present it
spreads now so this guy mentioned case
studies exactly right i could tell you
15 case studies of people who did this
but if we look to the odds this approach
just sucks on average you're going to
fail
so if you're in an organization that
really sucks and you're a low-level
person to me you've got three choices
one you get out as fast as you can
because you're going to start becoming
like those jerks
in incompetent people you work with it's
very contagious
the second thing you can do is to form a
posse of people don't just fight the man
or women yourself
um because a lot of evidence that that
when you try
to be an individual deviant they just
label you so form a group of people and
that sort of political action
and then the third thing and this is i
think a temporary solution but and i
hate to say it i'm sure i've done this
in my life you know when you have those
really bad classes
and you just say to yourself this good
thing about the quarter system by the
way this class just sucks
and and because you know i have three
kids and i'm used to them having classes
that suck and we just say to them
suck it up to use that term and just get
through it and learn the fine art of
emotional detachment sometimes
you know like life is like a bad
airplane ride and i
you know we've all had the bad airplane
ride you know like you get bumped and
i had this about three weeks ago i'm in
the last row
um middle seat by the bathrooms in a
giant plate
and i'm a big guy but the two guys on
either side of me have at least 50
pounds each heavier than me
so i shut my eyes ordered a double
bourbon and imagined i was somewhere
else and tried not to give a
and and sometimes your job is like that
and it's not a good permanent solution
because i would still be drunk on that
airplane right
but but but sometimes just sort of like
you know the fine art of knowing when
not to give a is a really good um
technique but get out as fast as you can
as my quick advice
and i think we better end on that weird
question tom wants it to end
thank you
you